Amy or its got within style it's good to
see him so how has the process been
preparing for the dress that everybody's
gonna want to see when you step on the
outskirt red carpet um
sometimes I feel like I am dressing in
costume on the red carpet and this year
I want to feel like myself so I
guarantee when I'm on the red carpet
this year you can know that's a dress
that I would wear so it's not a
character's dress yes
about you I will do all different role
um I mean it was such a great
opportunity to play all of these
elements to her humanity but really
working with the actors I got to work
with that was my favorite part Christian
Bale Bradley Cooper Jeremy Renner and
Jennifer Lawrence I hope she's here
today although she's so busy with Hunger
Games but it was just such a great
opportunity to get to play off of them
what you saw he knew you have something
else inside of you tell us about David
is created two really diverse wonderful
different roles for me I'm very grateful
for that and David has a way of
challenging an actor past what they
think they're capable of and it's it's
almost in a way that um he just sort of
keeps on you until he you give him what
he saw in you when he wrote the role and
it's a wonderful wonderful thing and I'm
challenging and complicated but at the
end of the day you get to create these
characters that um hadn't existed in
your repertoire before so I'm really
grateful thank you so much